is it any wonder that people don't have
trust in these guys
in the bidens
and the fouchies
and all of these
creeps who are taking away our rights
and our way of life and our traditions
and our even our ability to dress
ourselves the way we want and forcing us
to muzzle ourselves
is it any wonder we don't like them very
much
well dr fauci has a different take
value says the reason people don't like
him very much
is not because of anything he's done
or any lies that he has told
or any
contempt that he has for the american
people it's because of conspiracy
theories
why do you think
you've become so controversial and
honestly do you think there's anything
you have done that has contributed to
that well i'm not so sure i could answer
the latter because i can't think of
anything but i'm sure some people will
but you know chris i have stood for
always making science data and evidence
be what we guide ourselves by
and i think people who feel differently
who have conspiracy theories who deny
reality that's looking them straight in
the eye those are people that don't
particularly care for me and that's
understandable because what i do and i
try very hard is to be guided by the
truth
and sometimes the truth becomes
inconvenient for some people so they
react against me that just is what it is
there's not much i can do about that
chris
i am the way and the truth in the life
okay and uh well hold on wait
uh
i think there is someone who is the way
in the truth in their life and i don't
think it's you
dr fauci
he i'm not i don't think i'm
exaggerating when i say that he just
said he is the truth and he said that
often he says i am science and science
is me and i am the truth people react
against me because they don't like the
truth right it's kind of a weird
rewriting of scripture
he says he's the way do what i'm doing
order your life in the way that i'm
telling you to and i am the life or
you'll die
if you don't do it i say you're going to
die
talk about a god complex man and to
chris wallace's credit he says hey hey
fouch
do you think maybe you bear any
any at all responsibility for the
opinion people have of you
nope
uh uh
not even a little bit no it's all them
they're bad and stupid
i'm dr fauci
good grief man what a you know he's a
really good politician you can tell
because he never admits that he did
anything wrong ever do you think the
reason people don't like you dr fouch
you might have something to do with the
fact that you lied to them at your very
first moment in the epidemic you said
masks don't work it's your opinion that
masks don't work and you shouldn't wear
them and then five seconds later you
said actually they do work and you
should wear them and then when asked to
explain it you said well yeah i lied to
them so that they wouldn't buy up all
the masks and then take them away from
the healthcare workers who i think
deserve the more yeah but believe me now
do you think it has anything to do with
that kind of stuff do you think it has
anything to do with 15 days to slow the
spread
that we're now entering our
595th day of just about
and it has anything to do with that
i think it has anything to do with your
not wearing a mask when you don't think
you're on camera with your cancelling
christmas with your
ceasing power and power more and more
and more power
with your
holding power in dc through seven
presidencies now yeah has anything to do
with that no
no no
they persecute me because i am the truth
oh
okay must have missed that i'm so glad
you enjoyed that clip i liked it too i
thought it was good
the way i said that thing about that it
was really good you can get the whole
show here
at this youtube channel you ring the
bell you subscribe that's great or you
go to the michael knowles show at apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
subscribe we really appreciate it really
helps us out to avoid some of the big
tech censorship issues
we'll see you over there and see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you